and Wired magazine takes an in-depth
look at a year's long string of
cyberattacks in Ukraine that could have
global implications July cover story how
to switch a country off investigates
what the author calls a sustained cyber
assault unlike the world as n ever seen
it is undermined every sector including
the media military politics and even
people's homes Andy Greenberg is the
author of the story Nicholas Thompson is
Wired's chief and editor-in-chief he's
also a CBS News contributor good morning
to both you're welcome a fascinating
piece let's start with exactly what
happened how big was this attack on the
power grid in Ukraine and who was behind
it well they're actually two so in
December 2015 for the first time in
history hackers who we believe now we're
Russian hackers took down the power for
a quarter million Ukrainians and three
regions of the country but then they
struck again a year later and not only
that but their attacks are evolving in
2015 they were attacking these
distribution stations that are kind of
like the capital areas of the electric
system in 2016 they took down a
transmission station which is more like
an artery so they got more sophisticated
a disturbing progression happening why
are they doing it Andy do you think well
Russia is at war with Ukraine and they
want to destabilize the country they
want to you know to make it look like a
failed state but then I think the really
disturbing thing is that they're also
using Ukraine as a testing ground for
attacks that they're honing to possibly
use against Western Europe or the United
States in the future in fact this there
may be now this may be a signal of an
imminent threat to the United States
right Nick you know it's a funny story
right because we saw these hacks going
on with Russia and Ukraine who said ok
we'll send Andy Greenberg to Ukraine
it'll be a terrifying story Andy goes to
Ukraine he reports it and it's actually
scarier than we thought because it turns
out they're not only doing all these
terrible things they're not only
shutting down the power grid and not
only shutting down the railway stations
it looks like they're kind of planning
to come after us so yeah we thought it
was bad and it was worse well Gil and I
said this morning Gail said to me Nora
I'm really worried about this this is
scary stuff yes because I do think it's
only a matter of time and I wonder how
prepared we are well I think that the
u.s. power grid actually of we have
better cyber security than Ukraine but
we also have a more automated grid that
in some ways is more Vil
able to cyberattack plus we're not as
good at you create as Ukraine at turning
the power back on they have black all
the time we you know I don't generally
have to like drive out in trucks to turn
the power on so you know it's probably
harder to take down our grid but it
might be easier to keep it down for a
longer period of time and I think you're
right that we have not fully prepared
for this the United States is not ready
for the kind of cyber tech that the
Ukraine has seen and we should probably
start getting our stuff together well
exactly but does your article and what
is going on actually indicate this is
tipping their hand and allowing us to
get prepared if they just done it as a
surprise on us we might not be prepared
does this help us because this is fairly
detailed exactly how it works well
that's part of the point of the article
I mean part of the point of the article
is to help make the case that these are
the things you should look at this is
what we should understand of course the
nature of cyber war is Andy is found is
that it's always changing and evolving
and the tools are different and the
targets are different but yes I hope the
people who protect our grid read Andy's
story and what do you would he make Andy
of the story that's breaking this
morning in the Washington Post about
Russian interference and hacking in the
u.s. election seems very timely
considering what you have one of the
most that you think points in that story
was that that Obama had authorized
similar attacks on the Russian grid if
if we wanted to and I think it's
important to realize that all of the
most powerful nations in the world US
Russia China probably have the ability
to take down each other's power grids
and infrastructure but the scary thing
is that Russia is brazen enough to
actually do these things they did it to
Ukraine they did metal in the u.s.
presidential election there's a kind of
boldness in the Putin regime that should
scare everyone right you might think
there'd be like mutually assured
destruction oh yeah they know we can
take down their grid so they won't come
after us
but they went after our election and we
didn't do anything that's oh it's not
sure that this is holding so well you
also point out in the article that as
deep as they went they could always go
deeper as bad as it seemed there they
could have it could have been much worse
which I also thought was very
interesting right so in the second of
these two power grid attacks they only
took the power down for one hour but
they used an incredibly sophisticated
new piece of malicious software the
automated the whole attack and seems
designed to be used again so that's
maybe like the most chilling aspect of
this is that they have a reusable
adaptable weapon that they're going to
want to use again Nick does the does the
answer require the federal government or
is this a private sector initiative
used to be - undertaken it's going to be
a whole part of it is going to be the
federal government we need much better
national tools but it is also a private
sector initiative they have to work hand
in glove and the private sector has to
vary certainly look at its own stuff
hire cybersecurity experts if you work
at a power grid you can't just rely on
the federal government talk about some
of the characters that you interviewed
in the article I thought that was so
fast so fascinating the Russians and the
Americans well my favorite character in
this story is Alexei ocinski okay yeah
cyber security researcher in Ukraine and
I saw him on YouTube give a talk about
one of those Power Grid attacks and I
thought you just have good technical
details I visited him in Kiev and it
turned out that not only he tracked
these hackers for more than a year but
they actually shut down the power in his
home that you know one night he was just
watching television with his family and
and the power went out and he he figured
out because it was exactly midnight
because was one year after the earlier
power grid attack that these hackers
he'd been tracking had reached out from
the internet into his home and turned
off the power and then it became
personal he's watching Snowden right
GTA's intronic yeah no really good work
credible reporting thank you so much I'm
just glad the lights stayed on this
whole cycle yes that's so far so good
it comes on and Andy Greenberg Congrats
the article appears in the July issue of
Wired magazine which hits newsstands on
June 27th that's not sweet